las enfermeras de Inglaterra Irlanda del
Norte y gales están exigiendo un
incremento salarial del 19.2% que esté
de acorde con la disparada inflación que
azota a todo el país sin embargo el
gobierno ha dicho que esa solicitud es
poco realista y les ha ofrecido un
cuatro tres por ciento de incremento por
la huelga fueron canceladas en el día de
hoy 70.000 operaciones y otros
procedimientos médicos pero los
tratamientos de cáncer atención de niños
de mujeres embarazadas y las emergencias
no estuvieron comprometidas las
enfermeras aseguran que no solo están
parando por un incremento salarial sino
para que se mejore el servicio en
general que tiene beneficios para los
pacientes y llamaron la atención que en
el sistema Público de salud británico en
eches hay vacantes de hasta 50.000
enfermeras una nueva jornada de la
huelga de enfermeras la primera en la
historia del país se está programada
para la próxima semana en estos días de
diciembre cada día hay un paro diferente
de un sector público distinto este
viernes se realizará una nueva jornada
de paro de los trabajadores de los
trenes con el país prácticamente
paralizado en una huelga cacique general
de diferentes sectores pone muchísima
más presión y pone en jaque a la débil
posición política del actual Primer
Ministro Richie suna